the order will start with questions the
secretary state for defense Steve McCabe
number one sir
Minister I good afternoon Mr Speaker the
mod continues to process our app
applications at PACE thanks to the
recruitment of more caseworkers and
improved systems and processes in the
first four months of 2023 we issued over
12 200 eligibility decisions we aim to
process all outstanding initial
applications by August 2023. Steve McKay
well I think the minister for the
response I've recently written to him
about a family still trapped in
Afghanistan whose case I was told in
January was being processed by the mod
but Mr Speaker it's about more than our
constituency case
the standing of our arms services are
affected by the scandals lately pilot
threatened with the Rwanda don't help
does the minister recognize that the
shambles over our treatment of Afghan
refugees is damaging the reputation of
our military with obvious implications
for future operations
Minister well Mr Speaker I certainly
don't recognize uh the connection that
The Honorable gentleman has made the
offer made through Aaron through the
scheme to bring Afghans who served
alongside the UK armed forces and whose
lives are at risk as a consequence to
the UK is being honored it continues to
be a major line of effort by the mod we
have had hundreds of thousands of
applications the vast majority of which
have come from people who either served
in the Afghan National forces who whilst
their effort was heroic was never who
arap was aimed at or even people who
never had anything to do with the UK
Armed Forces at all now their
desperation to leave their country is
understandable but the Arab scheme was
always what it was set up to be both the
evacuation of those who served alongside
the UK on forces and that continues to
be something that the mod is putting a
lot of effort into delivering and we
will complete the processing
applications by this summer so Julian
thank you Mr Speaker does my right
honorable friend the minister accept
that whilst
people who served with our armed forces
are at grave risk within Afghanistan
even when they cross the border into
Pakistan they are not out of danger if
they cross the border without papers
they could well be sent back so what
pressure are we putting on the Pakistani
authorities to make sure that no one who
served with British forces is sent back
to a terrible fate while we are
processing their applications minister
Mr Speaker the writer one chance gives
me the opportunity to pay tribute to the
Pakistan government and the cooperation
that they have shown in helping us to
deliver our app
um we are not encouraging people to
cross the border illegally and the
Pakistan government has given us a
number of Windows in which to bring
people across legitimately there's a
growth a grown Consular section at our
high Commission in Islamabad to support
those who are in Pakistan waiting for
their onward transportation to the UK
but clearly in the article which enter
has raised specific cases with me in the
past and if he knows of people who are
at risk who or who are being pursued in
a way that I don't think is our
agreement with the Pakistan government I
stand ready to take up their case
through our high commission with them
Patrick ready number two
seriously the national Maritime security
strategy details and the government's
approach to Maritime security the mod
funds direct operational activity
contributes to Maritime security
including continuous at Sea deterrent
ocean surveillance Maritime domain
awareness capabilities and additionally
the mod supports the joint Maritime
security Center a multi-agency
organization who support wide amount of
time security throughout the UK Marine
area including Scotland
Patrick ready I'm not entirely sure this
is the advert for the strong broad
shoulders and strength of the Union that
the minister would like to think that it
is can he confirm that there's so order
I'm sorry but we can have conversations
going on with the Box
Patrick thank you Mr Speaker I wonder if
the Secretary of State can confirm that
there's not a single armored surface
ship permanently based in Scotland right
now how exactly does that enhance our
Maritime security protect our undersea
cables or offshore infrastructure or
make Russia feel any less emboldened
about sailing into UK Waters
Thursday
well first of all there are some of the
most formidable subsurface boats in the
world based at fast lane then let me
tell you does make the Russians but of
course the SMP Mr Speaker to get rid of
that make ten thousand people redundant
and then fantasize about how that's
going to do it secondly a warship is
best used at Sea not at Port that's how
you deter Russia tying it up alongside
empty with no doubt the Scottish Navy
under an independent Scotland is hardly
going to frighten a person
right so let's just go to each other
secretary John Healy thank Mr Speaker
the defense secretary is right of course
for strong Maritime security we need our
Navy ships at Sea not in the dock for
repairs and for the last two years the
defense secretary has been telling us I
quote
we're on track to deliver more days at
sea for ships yeah in last year's data
eight of the Navy's active warships
never went to sea at all and the new
Prince of Wales carrier since it entered
service has spent just 267 days at Sea
and 411 days in dot for repeated repairs
so why is he still failing to get more
of our ships more of the time at Sea to
keep Britain safe Thursday well Mr
Speaker first of all it's very normal
for a third of a fleet to be alongside
for maintenance deep maintenance and
indeed preparation to sail and training
that is not unusual secondly the claim
that I made was to get more days at Sea
off the Navy rather than days alongside
and that is indeed the case if you talk
about more ships and more days at Sea he
makes a point that there are not enough
ships maybe at sea at the same time
which is exactly why I commissioned the
propulsion improvement process to get
the type 45s made under his government
actually back out to sea rather than
tied alongside we've now completed three
one at camel aired one at Portsmouth
second one in camel LED in in merseyside
with tremendous success and they will be
out and more available and if he wants
to talk about the aircraft carrier Mr
Speaker I'm responsible for lots of
things I didn't commission the build and
the design of this aircraft carrier that
we're having to rectify that would be
his party opposite
Christian weight question number three
Mr Speaker Minister thank you Mr Speaker
with your permission Mr Speaker I'd like
to answer this question question 3 and
15 together in the last seven years the
ministry of Defense has invested more
than 936 million pounds in service
family accommodation improvements
currently just under 97 of the mod SFA
meet or exceed the government's decent
home standard only these properties are
allocated to service families Christian
waitford thank you Mr Speaker over the
last couple years I've been fortunate to
visit bases across the UK and spoken to
many servicemen and service women
recurring themes about accommodation is
beyond poor and having seen family
accommodation first hand I'd have to
agree with them having seen cracks and
mold on the walls of family's bedrooms
the minister responded to a urgent
question on this topic on the 20th of
December so can you outline what his
department has done to improve this
awful situation for Heroes and their
families since then Minister well I'm
going for the London we all want to see
our Armed Forces service Personnel
staying in good living in good quality
accommodation and the key to that is of
course the investment which is why I
hope he will recognize and welcome the
huge investment we put into this space
936 million pounds in the last seven
years as I said 185 million pounds alone
and I can confirm investing at least a
further 1.8 billion pounds over the next
10 years
speaker I I welcome the investment that
has been put in over the last uh seven
years as the minister says but he's of
course dealing with a backlog from the
last 20. and will the minister visit RF
Odum in my constituency to see some of
the problems that have been caused by
poor contractors and to help discuss
some of the solutions needed with the
service families there well I'm I'm
grateful to my right on a friend and um
absolutely will be more than happy to
visit this is a really important issue I
do recognize the challenges that exist
um it's complex it's built up as he says
over many years
um but we're putting the investment in
place and we're determined to deal with
this issue
show them in a salute Polo yeah yeah
thank you Mr Speaker in March labor
launched homes fit for Heroes our
campaign to highlight the failings of
Defense Housing for service Personnel
one member of the Armed Forces who has
served for over two decades told us they
feel pushed to leave the Army due to
their house being in such a state of
disrepair they describe it as unfit to
live in the government could have solved
this crisis over the past 13 years if
they wanted to but it's getting worse
and worse with Personnel leaving because
of poor housing will this problem be
fixed by the time of the next general
election or will the minister be leaving
it to the next Labor government to clean
up this Tory mess
[Music]
well it's a pleasure to engage with
labor front bench for the first time
um it's interesting uh Mr Speaker first
of all again it doesn't welcome the
significant investment we put in place
of course we do recognize that we've had
issues with mold and so on these have
been long-running long-standing I would
emphasize that the maintenance backlog
from December is now down by 75 but he
might want to reflect on the fact that
under his government he oversaw PFI
contracts for service properties which I
can convert in Bristol bath and
Portsmouth cost had a cost of 25 000
pounds per home whether they were
occupied or not Mr Speaker
number four Mr Speaker
with permission Mr Speaker I should like
to answer questions four five and eight
together we continue to deliver a range
of services to our veterans and their
families which include pension and
compensation payments and tailored
support through our veterans welfare
service and defense transition Services
we are also pressing ahead with our 40
million pound transformation program
which will digitize all paper-based
practices involving improving processes
and creating a single entry point for
pensions and compensation by the end of
2024. David thank you Mr Speaker the
number of claims leading to financial
compensation through the Armed Forces
compensation scheme has dropped from 65
percent to 47 percent since 2011 to 12
while rejections Rose from 24 to 41 can
the minister say why this is and how
does he and the veterans UK plan to
address this
Minister well Mr Speaker the
digitization program that I referred to
in my initial response to the onboard
lady's question will make a big
difference and in fact the early
evidence is that that is the case my
right honorable friend the minister for
Veterans Affairs recently visited
veterans UK and was hugely encouraged by
what he saw and my rights will offend
the minister for defense people and
Veterans who sends his apologies Mr
Speaker for not being able to be here
today is on this very closely I suspect
that whatever the failings of the past
the transformation process should lead
to significantly better outcomes
the minister will know that 14 of
veterans in England and Wales are female
and in a recent survey 23 of those
veterans said they'd suffered from
sexual harassment while seeing the Armed
Forces for the 23 said they'd they'd
been subject to emotional bullying these
have significantly contributed to the
PTSD cases in female veterans can the
minister set up what the government are
doing to try and ensure these veterans
get the most best support they can into
his show we actually get the support
while they're serving so we can
encourage more women during the armed
forces and meet the government's targets
of 30 of armed forces being female in
the next five years yeah vanister what
Mr Speaker can I Thank The Honorable
gentleman for raising such an important
issue and gives me opportunity to pay
tribute to the work done by a normal
friend
um uh both uh during her time on the
defense select committee and in her time
as a minister in the department this is
an issue that the department is working
on the defense secretary has made it a
priority that we had address any
remaining issues around the culture
within our armed forces and as we are in
general notes in his question we need to
make sure that that extends to the
support we offer to female Veterans as
well well it's Cunningham thank you Mr
Speaker further to the question is my
honorable friend the member for
buildingham Birmingham sell York
ministers will be aware of the series of
articles in The Independent Newspaper
campaigning for Asylum protection for
the veteran Afghan pilots and others who
fought with the British forces in
Afghanistan a great personal mental and
physical cost can the Secretary of State
confirm once and for all that these
veterans will have their Asylum
applications process quickly and not one
of them will be deported to Rwanda or
anywhere else
stuff well Mr Speaker The Honorable
gentleman is referring to a veteran of
the Afghan National Security Forces
rather than the UK security forces and I
said in response to the original
question on our app the terms of Arab
from the very beginning were around
those who had worked with the UK armed
forces in direct support of our role in
Afghanistan not the entirety of the
Afghan Afghan National Security forces
the case that he refers to the gentleman
only applied on the 9th of April we are
looking at whether or not there are any
special circumstances under which his
application could be approved but in
Principle as a member of the Afghan
National forces Security Forces rather
than somebody who worked alongside the
British Armed Forces he would not
automatically be in scope
James Ray Mr Speaker there is one group
of Veterans for whom a terrible
Injustice was done many years ago now uh
namely the lgbtq plus uh solder sales in
Airman before 2001 who lost their rank
who were dismissed who lost their
pensions and to this day that has not
been restored now I know that the
government who appointed Lord Levinson
to look into this matter and try and put
rewrite some of these wrongs when will
that report be brought for the house
will there be an oral statement on the
matter so we can cross-examine ministers
on it and doesn't is Mr confident that
he will now find a way of writing those
Dreadful wrongs
Mr Speaker I I personally agree very
much for the sentiment of the of my
honorable friends question
um the the way that people who were gay
was treated with during their service in
the armed forces in earlier time
um does not reflect the values of the
modern British armed forces and the
review I'm told will be here soon and we
will make sure that its lessons I
learned and adopted by the department
Michael Benning
very much Mr Speaker today's the 15th of
May the day that Captain Robert norack
from the first Battalion of grindley
gods was taken by the IRA and murdered
his murderers are still walking free and
we don't know the truth would the
minister acknowledge that those that
served are not Banner need to know the
truth about what happened to Captain
Robert norick and the Dexter and group
veteran groups in Micah Stitcher my
friends honorable friends constituency
led by David brocklehurst who certainly
was killed on Monday in a road traffic
accident need the support of the
veterans Minister as we go forward
following the success of Peace in
Northern Ireland but no peace when we
don't know who murdered Captain Norwich
well Mr Speaker
um I too read over the weekend that the
anniversary of the death of Captain Iraq
was today
um and his uh cases are particularly
um barbaric one
um there is a great deal of work going
into the legacy of the troubles and how
investigation should or should not be
progressed my rights honorable friend
the minister for Veterans Affairs leads
on that I know he will have heard the
question all right humble friend asked
today and I'm sure he'll want to pick up
the issues with him in due course
thank you Mr Speaker could my honorable
friend update the house on the progress
of the rollout of uh veterans ID cards
which I understand due to be completed
by Remembrance Day this year
Minister uh well Mr Speaker I have no
reason to believe that the right The
Honorable gentleman's expectations are
inaccurate but I will make sure that the
Minister of Defense people and Veterans
rights to him in case that is not the
case
we could show an administer Rachel
Hopkins
thank you Mr Speaker and tomorrow is the
60th anniversary of the last servicemen
being stood down from national service
and so may I express our thanks to all
those who served
headline findings of the five-year
review of the Armed Forces compensation
scheme found the process overly
burdensome and even distressing I've
heard many complaints about the scheme
from veterans and their families and I'm
sure ministers have
so with the government missing its own
casework targets delaying action on the
scheme isn't good enough as it continues
to let down our Armed Forces community
so can I press the minister on when we
will see the final report of the review
and can he confirm that there will be
meaningful improvements made to the
scheme before summer recess
Modesto
um well Mr Speaker as I've said in
response to earlier questions around 40
million pounds is being invested in the
ongoing transformation process to
digitize the existing paper-based
processes and records and that will be
transformative these are hundreds of
thousands of Records kept largely on
paper which make them extraordinarily
difficult to process and have caused all
of the delays that the rights that The
Honorable lady rightly mentions but
since the new online digital claim
service was launched through the gov.uk
website the service has been available
to service personnel and Veterans the
new service has been well received and
already accounts for 50 of all new
injury and illness claims being made
thank you Mr Speaker question six
Thursday Mr Speaker with the mission I'd
like to answer questions 6 and 21
together defense was pivotal on the
success of the wider government effort
to evacuate British passport holders and
other eligible persons from Sudan a
range of UK military assets and
capabilities were deployed in our
response resulting in the evacuation for
more than 2 400 people the longest and
largest evacuation of any Western Nation
from Sudan thank my right on my friend
for that answer a constituent of mine
must hold up in a cartoon Corridor with
a French family four days and able to
receive fcdo email or Whatsapp
instructions due to the power outages
and my office was having to relay
updates to their distressed family now
mercifully Mr Speaker he was airlifted
out by the French Ahmed Lair and whilst
recognizing the complex and challenging
nature of the evacuation what can his
Majesty's government do to help improve
awareness of and Communications with
stranded British citizens in potentially
unstable states to enable our Armed
Forces to amount efficient and effective
airlifts in the future
so to State The Honorable friend raises
an important point but also not an easy
issue to solve in somewhere like Sudan
obviously we were seeing less than
single digit coverage or access to the
internet at any one time in the middle
of a effectively a Civil War as it was
then for defense it's an easier thing to
solve we bring our own Communications
with us and when 16 Air Assault Brigade
deployed we'd managed to bring a limited
amount of capability that we could try
and communicate with British citizens
and for the main part it is a policy
Primacy of the foreign office we're
always stand by to help them with that
advice but of course I would also advise
that Travelers look advice before they
travel and indeed uh we we have to find
a way through that challenge in
Communications denied space but it is
not straightforward or easy don't drop
them thank you very much Mr Speaker I've
been seeing some of the amazing work
that the Royal Air Force does through my
membership of the Armed Forces
parliamentary scheme so can my right
honorable friend so I mean
congratulating the work that the RAF did
in Sudan evacuating over 2 500 people
from over 24 countries under very
dangerous circumstances and can he
inform the house which other
stakeholders made the so successful so
we can recognize Fair work and thank
them as well
so I've stayed my honorable friend is
right to highlight the RAF to fly into
an Airfield with unsure conditions often
in the dark without much of a advance
recce is some achievement we also saw
the RAF do that in Kabul uh if you
remember in that large uh evacuation
alongside the RAF where specialist unit
from 16 years that actually helped fix
the runway because of course this Runway
was not used to the level of demand
placed on it and only Britain had that
ability they flew in they helped fix the
runway that allowed a better
relationship the Sudanese armed forces
that allowed us to continue that longer
term evacuation and I think that's an
example of the breadth of experience
that we carry in the armed forces you
very much Mr Speaker three of the four
Atlas aircrafts used in the evaluation
of British Nationals from Sudan are
reported to have developed faults
two-thirds of the income in Fleet is
listed as unavailable and there it means
no Clarity the fleet can perform the
niche functions are special air and
Services need hasn't the Secretary of
State made a mistake in pressing ahead
with ditch in the Hercules feet in their
favor
but speaking I've heard these sort of
tired arguments about what we really
need to do is just keep the hurk and get
rid of the l400 outperforms the hurt on
most tight it's got a longer range
bigger capacity you can land in the same
area in fact can land in shorter
distance and in Kabul of the massive
evacuation combo the a400 1A 400 had a
fault for six hours and managed to
continue on its course the over 100 is
performing and as far as the migration
to Special Forces and other capabilities
that is on track already having done
jumps from it and other parts of the
area the simple reality is over 100
outperforms it its availability was
extremely successful that the Hercules
only accounts for 10 of the fleet and
the overall Fleet for Lyft is now the
biggest it's been for 50 years
John Spiller uh thank you Mr Mr Speaker
and I can I sort of join the Secretary
of State and congratulations to our
Armed Forces on their role here as
indeed in Afghanistan but isn't there a
problem that in Afghanistan Sudan but
also when during covid lots of our
citizens were stranded behind the uh
around the world that in fact while the
ministry of defense was up for early
action the foreign office wasn't can we
ask that within the Machinery of
government we actually get a stronger
role for the mod so we get the can-do
attitude of the mod rather than the
can't do attitude of the foreign
gentleman opposite in making sure that
the resilience of the uh whole of
government is supported by the mod there
are definitely lessons to be learned
I'll make sure those lessons are taken
away and shared across government
Paul Holmes thank you Mr Speaker
question number seven
Minister thank you Mr Speaker with your
permission I'd like to answer questions
7 and 24 together the UK scores highly
in the global rankings for defense
exports which creates jobs and
prosperity across the country building
the industrial resilience and capacity
we need for our national security
through the defense and security
industrial strategy thesis we and
Industry are strengthening our position
by diversing our diversifying our
exports and Target markets and by
collaborating more closely sir Bob
Holmes thank you Mr Speaker I welcome
the Department's announcement that both
Germany and the United Kingdom will work
together on the development of advanced
armor-piercing tank ammunition given
these new rounds will be able to be
fired from both British and German tanks
supporting capability compatibility
within NATO what export potential does
this new capability have well I'm
automobile friend and he is right to
highlight this important collaboration
with one of our major allies enhanced
kinetic energy Munitions are a key part
of the Challenger 3 and leopard 2 main
battle tanks programs and will deliver
battle-winning capabilities to UK and
German Armed Forces I am confident that
their Advanced performance will be
recognized as World leading and their
export potential to Nato and other
allies will be promoted by the mod as
and as ever in close partnership with
Department of Business and trade
thank you Mr Speaker can I congratulate
the defense secretary and all ministers
past and present who play may have
played their part in securing the 1.9
billion pound export deal for missiles
with Poland and does he therefore also
agree with me that we can significantly
strengthen our defense and security
security relationship with Brazil and so
we can increase export to that country
too
he is absolutely right to celebrate a
Great British success story
um the mbda British design common
anti-air modular missile is the latest
Generation air defense system in service
with the Royal Navy and British Army and
Mr Speaker I'm sure you'll be interested
to know it can engage targets up to 25
kilometers away and is capable of
hitting a tennis ball sized object
traveling beyond the speed of sound it's
already deployed in Poland to protect
its airspace following Putin's barbaric
invasion of Ukraine we work closely with
the Department of Business in trade
supporting UK Industries export campaign
through dedicated teams this network is
supporting delivery of numerous cam
campaigns and I can confirm to him we
have a positive defense relationship
with Brazil he makes a very good point
the mod continues to work with the
Brazilian mod and Armed Forces on how we
and UK industry can support their
equipment capability shortfalls and
development requirements Eric Smith
question nine sir Thursday Mr Speaker I
recently accompanied prime minister
Albany is to Baron furnace with the next
generation of orcas nuclear submarines
will be built for the Royal Navy a
testament our joint commitment this
multi-decade undertaking will create
thousands of jobs United Kingdom
delivering on the prime minister's
priority to grow the economy and
demonstrates experience and skill that
embodies British industry
thank you Mr Speaker I very much welcome
the Australian government's decision to
design their submarines on the SSN orcus
model and I understand that the
Australian prime minister Albanese was
in Barrow recently to see that work
what assessment has my reasonable friend
made of the benefits of orcus and the
design being made in this country in in
terms of the supply chain across the
United Kingdom State uh building really
complicated machines like submarines has
the benefit of a very a long and Broad
supply chain the orcus model is going to
be truly collaborative well based on a
UK ssnr I expect it over time to be
built by Australian hands United States
skills and supply chain alongside
ourselves which will be give
opportunities to both Australia and
United States and ourselves for
supplying a number of these submarines
that's good news for British industry
good news for skills in places like
Baron furnace but also good news for our
alliances with Australia and the United
States cavan Jones
can I thank the secretary for his uh his
response to that statement I visited
Austria last year and saw the great work
that Australians are undertaking on
Orcas it's a great National Endeavor is
he confident that in the UK
business department and others actually
realized that if we are going to get the
benefit out of this exciting project we
need that National Endeavor here
especially for example on skills and
Technology across government Thursday
well the right honorable we don't want
to know that to get signed off on a
project like this involves me engaging
right across government including the
treasury to get their buy-in and once
that has been locked in we then obvious
course could progress so I am confident
that the whole of government stands
behind this it's really important not
just to regenerate places like Cumbria
and the Northwest but also to lock in a
skill base we need for our future I
think it's a really exciting project
it'll be building long after you and I
are probably left this house in many
decades to come but you know Britain has
been at this game for 70 years to the
year of nuclear submarines that is not
something that you commit and back out
of we expect Australia alongside the
United States and ourselves to be doing
this for very long time to benefit
British jobs so the minister Chris Evans
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker can I welcome the
new minister to his place I got on with
all of his predecessors and I look
forward to our exchanges in future as
has already been said the orcas
agreement is a real game changer for not
only for our forces but also for British
industry now the government has promised
a jobs Bonanza for generations to come
in places like Derby Baro in finesse and
devonport in my honorable friends
constituency will This Promise be
underwritten by congratul contractual
guarantees and ensure that future
Generations are training the skills that
we need for this fighter program
first of all uh they are already
underwritten by contractor guarantees in
Baron Fern is bae are recruiting from 11
000 to 17 000 jobs Derby itself is
investing for the next generation of
reactor and that is starting so the key
point of August is not only it gets a
commitment from from treasury in the
government for the British replacement
of The Institute class but it locks in
that potential of Australian supply
chain and working together
collaboratively not only for skills here
but also in Australia so it is already
under that process two billion pounds
were unlocked recently to start building
the in infrastructure needed both in
Derby and Bae in Barrow and we'll
continue to do it so this is the not
just the beginning this is actually
further down the path but the real start
work Starts Now Neil hamburger number 10
Mr Speaker Mr
thank you Mr Speaker the Dreadnought
submarine program remains within overall
budget and on track for the first of
class HMS Dreadnought to enter service
in the early 2030s
as the program is in its preliminary
phases it is too early to provide cost
estimates for the replacement Warhead
program
thank you Mr Speaker the financial cost
of wmds is one thing but the potential
cumin cost from radiation leaks is quite
another on the 7th of November last year
I raised concerns from a whistleblower
about a serious a serious radiation
breach at corporate and lot long the
Secretary of State promised he would
provide a detailed written response
despite my persistent six months later
I've not had to reply other than uh
leaked to uh the media saying that the
alleged radiation incident referred to
didn't take place so can the Secretary
of State conform today from this
dispatch box if hmnb Clyde's staff were
moved from building 201 in coolport to a
building 41 elsewhere due to a serious
radiation breach
Minister well I'm grateful obviously
I'll have to look into this matter and
write to him further but I just make one
point he talks about the other costs if
I may say whilst the SNP has a as they
merely had I said whilst the SNP has a
merely quirky position of unilateral
nuclear song but remaining in NATO
supposedly the position of his party the
Alba party is both nuclear disarmament
and the withdrawal from NATO we ask
ourselves what would be the cost of that
policy in light of the current situation
where Russia has invaded Ukraine what
would happen if we were to announce our
withdrawal for NATO he used to reflect
on the cost
please
that was a long not really answering the
question I think what I'm more concerned
about was in that question six months
ago the letter was put in there's not
been a reply can somebody check that
because I'm bothered about MPS getting
replies from ministers not scoring
points let's go to Dr Luke Evans number
11 Mr Speaker so speaker I will endeavor
to make sure that that reply is got the
honorable member and find out why it has
taken so long I think it is too long if
that has been the case maybe we put it
in the camper van right Mr Speaker the
UK and international partners are
committed to providing the capabilities
Ukraine requires including training
artillery air defense and armored
vehicles and to drive further
International donations and resolve this
war however the Ukrainian people should
not be forced into concessions to ensure
the Ukraine is in the best possible
position to negotiate the UK and its
Partners will continue to provide
military and economic support uh apply
sanctions and increase International
pressure on Russia it's not Luke Evans
NATO's key strategic concept is that to
be ensuring the collective defense of
its members now the best way to do this
is to secure peace in the Ukraine but
Givens Russian aggression I support UK
and nato in its work so what assessment
has the Secretary of State made of the
likelihood of securing peace and failing
that the defensive capabilities of the
alliance should a war escalate
Thursday well first of all NATO's done a
lot of work to make sure that it is
ready and not only from February when
The Invasion started but to make sure
that we use that Readiness to deter
Russia on the borders of NATO and that
is incredible important and to date we
have not seen any deliberate strikes
into a NATO country by Russia and while
we have seen events in the Black Sea
deeply provocative Russia is so far
respecting those NATO borders I think
the most important thing here is to make
sure President Putin realizes he cannot
win this war in Ukraine that his
brutality is having the opposite effect
driven to new nations into NATO and and
the West including the United Kingdom
and now I saw some announcement in
Germany stepping up more and more to
make sure Ukraine has success on the
battlefield so it can negotiate if it
wishes to from a position of strength
thank you Mr Speaker well we on this
side stand firmly behind support for
Ukraine but Ukraine is depleting our
military stockpiles and the government
seems to be acting too slowly to
replenish them so what progress is the
Secretary of State made on a stockpile
strategy and what talks has he had with
NATO allies about their replenishment
plans to ensure the most effective
sequencing of replenishment
so stay and The Honorable leader makes
an important point that is not just
common to the United Kingdom across
Europe uh Ukraine has woken everyone up
to the issues around things like
ammunition stocks the first challenge
was to indeed wake up that supply chain
that many of the orders we'd had placed
in the past have been filled and then
the supply chain had gone through
something else we have done that and now
we have placed orders for new end laws
if you remember at the beginning the
entertain weapons new anti-aircraft uh
missiles obviously from talus in
Northern Ireland in conjunction with our
Swedish and I think Finnish colleagues
and we are currently in the process of
hopefully awarding a contract for 155
shells to replenish at the same time
I've worked across the International
Community to make sure we try and
stimulate those Supply chains to make
sure Ukraine go as well
thank you very much uh Mr Speaker could
I welcome the visit of president
zielinski to the UK today there's
clearly a warm relationship developing
between the president and our prime
minister we have a proud track record of
providing those end laws first to do so
providing trading on soldering plane
providing those main battle tanks
providing those long-range uh weapon
systems what next maybe fast Jets as
well there's much talk of a
counter-offensive but could I ask the
Secretary of State about the comments of
The Afghani pregosin the leader of the
Wagner group now openly criticizing
President Putin right absence of an
ammunition tactics on the battlefield as
well is he concerned that if this
counter-offensive is successful that
terrain is gained that Russia Putin will
turn ugly and resort to non-conventional
chemical weapon systems such as chemical
weapons and biological as he did in uh
Syria Thursday
look we always have to be on our guard
about the behaviors of the Russian
military and indeed President Putin as
he rightly comments the use of chemical
weapons in Syria was another Turning
Point the use of chemical weapons here
on the streets of the United Kingdom in
the poison of in scripples poisoning in
Salisbury we are on our guard the entire
Community regularly communicates We
Stand ready with NATO we increase our
Readiness as we do and we have started
to increase the investment in our
capabilities all important but he is
right we have to be very much on our
guard about what happens next okay my
group sorry
speaker I think I'll show that NATO
allies and partner countries have
provided Ukraine with more than 98 of
the combat vehicles that were promised
what steps and ministers taking to
ensure that your team continues to see
high levels of support from NATO
uh we NATO allies regularly meet
alongside other International Partners
at Ramstein in Germany where it is a U.S
chaired donation conference which built
on my first initial International
conferences it is a regular drum beat to
keep up on that and as you can tell
president zielinski and and of course
other members of his government are
regular visitors to International
communities to keep that momentum going
Britain is at the Forefront of that
momentum will continue to do so our
determinations to see it through Dan
Jones number 13 Mr Speaker
minister thank you Mr Speaker we are
driving the delivery of capabilities
front line when requirements budget and
risk are clear we have proven our
ability to deliver and the majority of
our programs are on or ahead of time and
budget the ministry of defense is set
out an affordable 10-year equipment plan
to ensure that our armed forces are
being given what they need whilst living
within our means Dan Jarvis thank you Mr
Speaker I heard what the Secretary of
State said earlier about Atlas and he's
previously given me commitments that
there wouldn't be any loss of capability
but today Deborah Haynes at Sky News is
reporting that the UK will be left
dangerously exposed when the c-130j is
cut next month and this comes amid
concerns that its successor the atlas
a400m has yet to be cleared to perform
the niche but Mission critical functions
of the c-130j so can I ask the minister
to give an absolute assurance that our
defense procurement system will ensure
that there is no loss of operational
capability I am more than happy to give
him that Assurance I know that there is
a great deal of affection for the
Hercules but just to go back to what the
secretary of state was talking about in
terms of the recent performance in Sudan
it's such an important operation the
largest number of evacuees carried out
from Sudan by Hercules was 143. the
largest number in an a400 I can confirm
was around 100 more than that
Dave Dugan the SMP spokesperson yeah
yeah thank you Mr Speaker continuity
focus on a Relentless grip on the detail
are the Hallmarks of a competent defense
procurement Minister now in less than a
year we're on our fourth defense
procurement minister so we haven't got
the continuity bit nailed down can the
new Minister reassure the house of his
competence by perhaps enlightening us to
the most challenging defense procurement
issue on his desk this week
I think I look to my left and right and
I do see continuity uh Mr Speaker
um of course I'm grateful to following
the steps of my rhyming friend for
Cheltenham who is now the law Chancellor
and Secretary of State for justice who
did a sterling job
um I think I would say to give one
example obviously
previously mentioned this about the
issue of replenishment and I have
recently had the privilege to um to
visit British troops training Ukrainian
forces as the chair of the state
committee referred to earlier and we
have to remember it's not just that we
are training 15 000 Personnel to go back
out to Ukraine and defend their Homeland
but every time they go we are giving
them the kit high quality kit which
sorry we're giving them high quality kit
and I think there are lessons to learn
from what's happening in Ukraine but we
should be incredibly proud of that
effort we've procured at PACE we've
gifted in kind and we have ensured that
Ukraine has been able to sustain its
fight to this day
well that's Crystal Clear uh Mr speaker
however one of the things he said
talking about Ukraine an answer to my
question about procurement was about
replenishment and he will know even in
his short tenure in the job the smes are
the lifeblood of any military-industrial
complex so can he explain why an answer
to my parliamentary question a couple of
weeks ago asking if the mod would attend
a public sector meet the buyer event in
Edinburgh which is attended by other UK
government departments this 50 billion
pound resource organization in the mod
cited a lack of resource for attending
that meet the buyer event is that a
special kind of indifference that's
reserved for Scotland
of course not I mean I'm happy to look
into that I just want to assure him the
latest figures Mr Speaker so the
proportion of mod spend with mods has
increased from 19.3 percent in 2018 19
to 23 in 2021 I ran an SME before coming
to this place it wasn't a desk it wasn't
a defense Sesame but I know how
important they are they give us
creativity Innovation I want to work
with them and the primes delivering
British and British defense industry
because we see that as a key part of our
own defense capability
question 15 please Mr Speaker Thursday
the ukr allies and partners continue to
respond decisively to support Ukraine as
the conflict evolves we have trained
over 15 000 recruits provided 2.4
billion pounds of support including
artillery ammunition as well as leading
the world on gifting of vital
capabilities such as the multi-launch
rocket systems Challenger 2 tanks and
nice Storm Shadow missiles
Mr Speaker can I congratulate my right
honorable friend again on the
announcement on the delivery of
long-range Storm Shadow missiles to
Ukraine I'm proud that the UK has been
able to provide this vital capability to
the ukrainians ahead of their long
expected counter-offensive and given
that the ukrainians Mr Speaker will need
all the support they can for this can my
item real friend please reassure me that
the second spending round of the
international fund for Ukraine is
proceeding at PACE and when will might
we expect to see contracts placed with
the remaining 300 million pounds no
State well my honorable friend will be
glad to know that the round round two
was launched last month and there's
seeking the expression of interest in a
phased approach beginning with the need
for air defense long-range strike and
Mobility support which will also be open
to huge numbers of smes to obviously
apply submissions are being assessed
right now and more requirements will be
launched in the coming weeks successful
companies will be chosen by the UK
alongside our irview partners and
Contracting will begin as soon as
possible we now move to topicals with
Catherine McKinnon topical number one Mr
Speaker Thursday
Mr Speaker I'd like to place on record
my thanks to all the members of our
Armed Forces who contribute to the
coronation parade it was it was a
remarkable day in the history of the
nation it was both an immense privilege
and a solemn responsibility for the
ministry of defense and our Armed Forces
to fulfill I would like to thank them
once again for contributing in an
exemplary way and with such
extraordinary personal commitment and
dedication while also meeting all other
operational requirements we are
immensely proud of you all our
privileged to belong to the defense
community
thank you and I very much Echo the
Secretary of State's comments in their
entirety the visit of president zolensky
today highlights how vital a collective
approach is to our National Defense and
security so to that end what steps is
the government taking to ensure we have
security and defense agreements in place
with our nearest
um allies in response to Russian
aggression or nearest allies in Europe
The Honorable lady is absolutely right
and we get our strength through
Coalition we get our strength through
our alliances and NATO is obviously the
most successful military Alliance the
world has seen but in addition to that I
led the way in making sure that
countries weren't covered by NATO at the
time Sweden and Finland uh signed
together a sort of mutual defense pact
that we did back about two years ago we
no one fought by then that they would be
joining NATO so what we do is we
encourage people to join NATO where they
apply in the open door policy and at the
same time other nations we seek to join
with mous and other agreements to try
and bolster that enabling Alliance
thank you following on from the
groundbreaking work that my honorable
friend for wrexham did on the experience
of women in the military constituents in
Delhi were pleased to hear the
announcement of a women's veteran
strategy
could the minister provide us with an
update and a timeline as to when that
might be implemented
I can I will write to him because that
will be the responsibility of the Office
of Veterans Affairs in detail but I'm
very happy to go further with that with
them and explain the details so
Secretary of State John petely thank you
Mr Speaker we welcome president
zielinski's visit and the extra military
aid announced today and Ukraine has
reinforced the importance of strong
deterrence uh and army numbers while
NATO is responding by increasing its
high Readiness Force to three hundred
thousand the defense secretary is still
set on cutting the British army to its
smallest size since Napoleon so will he
halt these Cuts in next month's Defense
command Paper Thursday
speak I've been really clear that this
is not a numbers game this is about
making sure whatever size our Armed
Forces is we have a completely well
equipped well looked after Workforce if
we just simply go on a numbers game
without the appropriate funding and I've
heard no commitments from the labor
party Mr Speaker we we live we go back
to a world that I served in under both
governments where we had numbers on
paper numbers on Paragon that Hollow
forces I won't repeat that I'll make
sure that whatever we have is fully
equipped and fully 360 and that's the
real lesson of Ukraine
well labors argued for over two years
for a halt to these Cuts Mr Speaker and
despite his Bluster the truth is he's
failed to get the new money for defense
apart from nuclear and for stockpiles so
why won't he just admit it
far from responding to the threats that
Britain faces he's cutting the Army to
cut costs
stay well I mean I you know it's like
through the Looking Glass Mr Speaker I
mean the reality is I've achieved as
defense sector an increase of over 24
billion pounds gusting further both in
Ardell in in parts and also in capital
spend it's simply important as house
understands that the world is changing
the battlefield is changing and if we
simply go to a numbers game we'll head
back to a first world war what we need
what we need is to learn the lessons
equip people properly support them
properly and I still haven't heard from
the opposite side a single mention of
their defense budget because of course
reversing the cuts will cost billions of
pounds I hear nothing so far I don't
think with any responsibility today so
we'll go to Dr Luke Evan thank you Miss
speaking I've recently had the privilege
to become the honorary Hinckley Branch
Royal British Legion president
and my first engagement was to join the
Hinckley armed forces and veterans
breakfast club in the handsome Cab in
Burbage for their fifth year celebration
now this amazing organization helps
veteran men and women providing the
support companionship and banter for
those who've served will he thank all
those who give their time and more
importantly what more can you do to
support those in the armed forces and
the veterans breakfast clubs
Minister uh Mr Speaker or may I
congratulate my honorable friend on his
presidential duties at the Hinckley
Branch Legion my own branch in
burnham-on-sea will just about let me
make the tea
um the he's absolutely right to draw
attention to the Fantastic work of
veterans breakfast clubs the government
has supported them through the Armed
Forces Covenant fund trust I know that
support is as well received in his
constituency as it is in my Mr Speaker
where there's an excellent Club in
Glastonbury Judith coming thank you Mr
Speaker with the UK today pledging a new
pack
Ukraine once
what I said of the pace of delivery of
these vital supplies to Ukraine
the United Kingdom has been at the
Forefront and ensuring right from the
start that the supplies get into the
country as soon as possible basing
people not only in Germany the
international a donor coordination cell
actually at the Hub of it over 70
military personnel there but also in the
neighboring countries to make sure the
logistics reaches the place in time
we're still managing to commit to that
pace some countries as president lensky
has said have have made pledges but part
of the delay is them getting their
equipment ready to donate I was already
in our 12 challenges are already in the
country we'll make sure we keep
monitoring it and pushing it as fast as
possible Sarah Atherton thank you Mr
Speaker the mayor of London has
generously permitted 54 000 friends and
family of tfl workers free travel around
London he's also granted police officers
from eight Services free travel when not
in uniform could the minister explain to
service Personnel particularly from
wallich Barracks why they can only
travel free whilst in full uniform which
makes them and those around them a
Target and whether there are any plans
to rectify this discrepancy
Minister well Mr Speaker
um the labor mayor of London is also
expanding the Euless charge which will
affect thousands of you of armed forces
Personnel who are based in the outer
boroughs I suspect that our colleagues
opposite will have heard this impact on
their cost of living and be urgently
encouraging their mayor to make sure
that free travel is extended to Armed
Forces Personnel traveling not in
uniform
ministers update the house as to how
ready the UK is to have more capability
at greater Readiness so that we can
continue to play our leading role in
NATO
Supreme melee Commander Europe recently
issued his Regional plans which extend
to 3 000 pages of detailed plans for the
defense of Europe and from that uh will
stem a donation conference where all the
member states put forward their
contribution to those plans within that
uh we'll develop the new fourth medal
model that will contribute to the new
Full structure of NATO and therefore
I'll be able to come later once we've
got through that period in the next few
months to tell the house exactly what we
have put forward how ready it is and
whether it meets the ass of the Supreme
Allied command of Europe
well Francois thank you sir Clive
Sheldon Casey of 11 Kings benchwalk
Chambers submitted his lessons learned
report on the Ajax program to the mods
some four months ago
but we're told it's still going through
a fact checking process
however there are growing rumors
that some people
who are adversely implicated in the
report are trying to water down or even
suppress its publication
as the Secretary of State personally
commissioned the report and as it's his
birthday today and as this is I think my
fourth time of asking can you please
give us all a birthday present and tell
us when it's actually going to be
published
happy birthday I hear thank you very
much what a birthday for speaking uh I I
hear the right honorable my right on my
friend he's absolutely right I have
asked not only because I have not yet
seen either the draft to see the draft
as well as the final report so I can
make sure that with my own eyes I decide
whether it's appropriate or not to be
changed I think it's incredibly
important it hasn't come to me yet I am
told after raising it recently that it
is imminent to make sure it comes to me
he's got a real Point here which is I'm
not into the business of shielding
people from their errors I'm interested
in learning lessons
Jamal Kendrick
Mr Speaker yourself the defense
secretary and myself have thousands of
constituents who work at BAE Systems in
Lancashire
they've been working obviously very hard
on typhoon F-35 but for the last couple
of years has been a great deal of
excitement and hype about the Tempest
program
it's at the moment I understand still a
concept uh in terms of its development
could the Secretary of State for defense
tell the house when detailed design and
production is likely to take place
my right on my friend uh raises an
important point for not only our part of
the world back to the whole United
Kingdom and its place in being able to
deliver a sovereign capability I
recently went to Japan where I signed
another agreement with my Japanese
counterpart on my Italian counterpart
the gcap program as it's now called but
to us it's Tempest is incredibly
important for jobs in the Northwest it
is already moving into the design phase
and then we'll get into the work the the
political balance of how much work share
is shared out amongst the partners but
there is a strong government commitment
to take this forward before the
tournament before 2030 we expect to see
test flight and then it will progress
strongly for all of our sakes Dr
Caroline Jones Thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker on the 1st of March there were
more than 22 000 Armed Forces Personnel
declared as category two or three on the
basis of their teeth meaning they have
suboptimal dental Fitness on top of that
my constituents who are the spouse
Independents of military personnel are
struggling due to the frequent house
move to get dental treatment Within nhsn
tell me what he is doing and his
department is doing to ensure that we
meet the obligations to our service
personnel and their families
Minister Mr Speaker I understand my
honorable friend Max with Maria tall
friend the Minister of Defense people
and Veterans recently
um to discuss this matter for defense
service Personnel their access to
Dentistry
um is more than it would be expected
um by the general population Beyond uh
where people are currently awaiting
Dental Care ahead of uh deployment their
care is prioritized as for the wider
issue relating to dental provision for
service families she raises an important
point I'll make sure it's reflected to
ministers in Department of Health and
Social care there are of course Armed
Forces government issues in the matter
she raises
Ford
thank you Mr speaker and it was good to
hear that the Apple door Shipyard in
Devon will see the construction of
modules for the three support ships the
Royal Fleet auxiliary as announced last
November
and it's been reported in the press in
the last week that shipyards belonging
to our Ally Poland will construct blocks
of Hull for the type 31 frigate with
final assembly carried out at osyth what
parts of the type 31 will be built in
Poland and what value will these amount
to
Thursday
my understanding is that the smallest
part one percent uh will be built in
Poland uh and that is uh of course
Babcock's decision made under that
original contract but overall it'll be
completed a recite I've already been up
there to visit and I'm also delighted
that for example under the contract
model we put together for future
sportship it enabled places like apple
door to get work because that is
important that we keep all our yards
busy and not just go from Feast to
famine Simon bench now thank you Mr
Speaker will my right honorable friend
comment on the ways in which the
ministry of defense is maximizing
defense procurement from Wales
particularly from Northeast Wales where
my constituency of clued South is
situated I'm grateful friend and Wells
plays an integral part in all aspects of
the UK's defense policy Mr Speaker with
a number of the mit's major suppliers
and smes having a presence there in 2021
for example mod awarded a 110 million
pound contract with the race and UK part
in North Wales which is providing the
Aria for one of the world's most modern
and cable intelligence gathering assets
we're also working with the Welsh
government and defense electronics and
components agency to create an advanced
technology Research Center at modc land
the atrc will develop cutting-edge
Sovereign capabilities to support
International collaboration job
sustainment and skills retention whilst
meeting or changing defense requirements
Tim Jones Thank you Mr Speaker I'd like
to start by thanking the PCS Union and
staff at DBS for the work and
negotiating important wins for disabled
and non-mobile staff who have been
offered flexible and type of work and is
a reasonable adjustment not forcing
staff to move without their agreement as
well the creation of a voluntary release
package is a positive step so come the
Secretary of State commit to ongoing
negotiations with PCS and Liverpool
staff to keep their terms under review
to ensure staff are given support
necessary to keep their jobs and under
reasonable conditions
well I'm grateful to The Honorable lady
and I'm glad that she recognizes I think
it has been a very constructive
negotiation as she mentions the offer
for example of flexible working
um as she knows today there have been no
compulsory uh redundancies and I would
just stress that even with the 30
million pound cost of the new site this
will bring a total 40 million pounds
saving so it's good value for taxpayers
as well as we believe a good deal for
the workforce of Courts can I welcome
the new Minister for this place it was
great to visit to event to visit
carterton recently I think for his first
visit where we discussed the upgrading
of existing mod housing and the purchase
of new and I look forward to discussing
that with him some more in the
subcommittee report that the defense
select committee will shortly be doing
but he also saw the large Brownfield
site known as Rima North which The Amity
housing has been demolished not yet
replaced because the money hasn't been
found to do it now we always talk about
prioritizing Brownfield land here's a
prime site where it's much needed and
the money hasn't yet been found will he
work with me to make sure that we not
only use this Brownfield land but we
protect West yorkshire's Land Supply and
give the RF homes they need
one of my friends very much enjoyed my
visit to Brian's morning it's actually
my second visit after Abbey Wood but
just to be clear we remain fully
committed to the development of new
housing at the rumor site for service
Personnel are in discussion with
industry Partners to facilitate
facilitate this but given the time
that's lapsed I'm happy to continue
engaging because I know that he's a
champion of his local service Personnel
Mr speaker Sony in serving the RAF more
than happy to stay engaged with him Alex
Doris the speaker in March 8 000 Afghan
relocations and assistant policy scheme
families were given eviction notices
from their hotel accommodation by the
home office what assurances can we hear
from the ministry of Defense ministers
that these people will not become
homeless
so I can only talk about for the Arab
cohort of people in the hotels at the
beginning of this process over half just
went straight into the community and
found places either with fans and
friends the ones in the hotel arap
lodges are different from the general
Asylum scheme they can claim benefits it
can claim housing benefit they can work
immediately they arrive it is time that
we find a way of getting them out into
the community and out of hotels so they
can start working they have that ability
that's the way that they can not only
integrate Society but actually get on
their own two feet and I think it it was
right at the time that we took a stand
that some of these people been there for
a long time it is time to move out and
use the rights they have coming here
under Ara
[Music]
speaker Mr Speaker I've been led to
believe that the issue facing the Prince
of Wales has been due to a almost
incredible complacency in Engineering
tolerances in the shaft may I ask my
honorable friend if there is any
Financial recourse to the manufacturer
in being able to get the Prince of Wales
operational again
[Laughter]
from the initial reports I have read uh
the misalignment of the shaft is
something around 0.8 millimeters or one
millimeter a tiny difference that of
course can make a huge difference I see
we are examining the liabilities and who
who should uh cough up for that the good
news is it hasn't delayed overall Prince
of wales's time and work up we took
advantage of some of these maintenance
periods to put in already pre-planned
maintenance and I think she's going to
be back on track and on time to deliver
her capability
have a holiday thank you Mr Speaker I
recently met with a school pupil called
Elizabeth Wilson who is also a member of
whole youth Parliament and the daughter
of an armed forces Personnel her
campaign is to establish an armed forces
Champion within every school to insist
peoples with transition but also to be
there to provide peer on peer support
what additional support can the minister
give to this young entrepreneur with
this project
Thursday I'm very happy to meet with
that young entrepreneur and indeed with
the minister of Veterans Affair I think
it's an excellent idea it would plug in
perfectly to the the local authorities
of forces Champions obviously with their
remit over local education I think it's
a really really good idea
Dean Russell thank you Mr Speaker may I
share my condolences for David
brockelhurst family uh he's been a
massive loss for the Abbott's Langley
veterans association as was mentioned by
my right on girlfriend for Pamela hemp
said earlier uh may I through the front
bench police thank the minister for
Veterans Affairs for his recent visit to
Watford to meet with veterans including
the Abbott Langley veterans associate
group to hear about the Fantastic
initiatives in Watford but also Luther
ballistic obes uh forces United
initiative thank you
Thursday our veterans are very very
important to the fabric of society it's
really important this is the best place
in the world to be a veteran I think we
this government's been on the right
track and delivering that yes there are
some things around a veterans card yes
or some things about the services but I
think you know the Armed Forces Covenant
the agreement of many parts of
government to support it is the right in
the right direction and we're going from
strength to strength hi Candace
thank you Mr Speaker in 1969 74 U.S
Personnel perished after the USS Evans
sank there were two Royal Navy personnel
from my constituency present who've just
been invited to a commemoration but
they're struggling to get there could a
minister meet with me to look at options
to enable them to help them get there
yeah Thursday I'll be delighted to try
and do that either through myself or the
defense veterans Minister James
Sunderland
Mr Speaker the minister will know that
I've got constituents in substandard
military accommodation at Sandhurst who
when they asked for help from the
Pinnacle SF contract over Christmas it
did not turn up could I please ask him
whether he will use the relative lull of
the summer months to plan ahead with the
contractors to make sure that we don't
have another problem at Christmas
and I've already met with the
contractors and Dio the good news is
that the maintenance issues around at
Christmas have been cut by 75 it's
continuing the right direction but he's
absolutely right the key here is going
to be planning ahead for the next winter
and that's what we're on with at the
moment and I'm very determined to hold
these contractors to account Douglas
chap thank you Mr Speaker uh HMS uh
Prince of Wales currently lies in Recife
for repairs and I hear it's been kind of
a lies for spare parts
well this three billion pound asset be
back in full operational duties by the
end of this year
yes by the Autumn and by the way
cannibalization it is perfectly normal
for ships to take ship stores from each
other this is not being cannibalized
because in somehow the ships off to be
mothball the ship is going to be back in
full service in autumn